you know i think you have to understand
you're in control
facebook and tick tock and podcasts and
youtube don't make you do anything yeah
they don't make you do anything
gary i'm asking this with love and you
know for me this was a big thing i i
think it was like
i think i'd been making content for two
years
before i introduced my community to my
wife yes
and
everyone's like jay you're married like
people had no idea because i just didn't
talk about her because we just got
married we'd been together for a few
years before that i was like i need to
be careful about of course what we're
going to say where this is going how
this feels you've recently been more
open about your relationship yes
we don't have to go there you're being
very kind and i appreciate it because i
respect you i'm asking it from the time
i am incredibly private as you know and
the world knows
because i'm going through a transition
in my life i felt like
it got to a place where it was not
sustainable for me to be 100 private and
so i've been a little more public it is
something that i'm
desperately not interested in even the
part we just talked about with my kids
like it's not somewhere i want to go i
don't want to go i don't want to talk
about my kids yeah i don't want to talk
about my personal weakness no no i want
you to keep this okay and i'll tell you
why i want to remind people you're in
control yeah
it's incredibly important and
appropriate and i appreciate especially
being very cordial for people to ask and
things of that nature but i want to
remind people they're in control yeah i
want to provide value and put out things
in my professional career
i'm incredibly private and
feel that the world is entitled to what
you give it
so when i watch people get upset when
people get into their business i'm like
you're giving them your business by the
way you're leveraging your business
i don't want to leverage nor give my
personal life to the world i don't think
that's the right way yeah by the way
yeah i just think it's my way yeah um so
the reason i have a little bit to what
you're referring to is it became not
sustainable because it's been a long
time and like i was in a transit like it
just it was the appropriate time yeah
and i needed to just get some context
out there but i'm uh it's not where i'm
gonna go yeah and that's what i was more
interested in to me it's not listen
us being together my brain goes into
maximize the value
at the highest levels because we have
the opportunity to for as many people
are listening the takeaway there from my
perspective is
you're in control yeah
you have a learning disability and you
want to share it mazel tov you don't
great yeah it took me back to something
less serious it took me
15 years of public life to say i'm not
candarous and it's hurt me my personal
life
and it's hurt me in my business life
you get to share what you want to share
yeah and and i think people
should be careful of what they share yes
you share your abs as a like as a like
you're a good shape dude people are
going to talk about your body for the
rest of your life yeah
yeah but you did that you're going to
show your kid all the time they're going
to talk about that relationship they're
gonna talk
you're giving the world permission yeah
i prefer not to give the world
permission because that's a sacred place
for me yeah you know even look at my mom
she like the greatest gift i could give
to the world is my mom to the world the
greatest
she's alpha me
she's more experienced she's a different
perspective as a mom as a she doesn't
want it the end
right
i thought my dad and mom would be
reverse
my dad i never thought would love the
limelight so much um but you know so
i think if you're listening right now
please
if you're not going on social media
because you have a skeleton in your
closet
you have a disease you have a bad you
know situation
you uh you're like me and like grew up
in a family where like personal life is
private that's i think you know in
russia that was like people would go to
jail if anybody knew anything about you
so i think it ingrained in my parents
which then ingrained in me and my sister
and brother like we're private that way
um you know i think you have to
understand you're in control
facebook and tick tock and podcasts and
youtube don't make you do anything yeah
they don't make you do anything i'm so
glad you addressed that because i think
there's and this is why i brought it up
i think there's been a
mosque of false vulnerability that's
been encouraged because of social media
so people think that the more vulnerable
or more open
that shows authenticity yeah i totally
disagree i love you for that you're
going to a very smart place i would
argue
i see more lack of authenticity in the
way that people are leveraging their
family and personal life
because they know it does well i think
the lack of accountability is leading to
so much unhappiness
like life is so much better when you're
like this was my fault yeah absolutely
you're in control yeah and so like you
know this was like a wrap up to control
you're in control you
you you decide what you consume you
decide what you believe you decide who
you surround yourself with you decide
what you put out
take on accountability yeah everybody
wants to blame right now the algorith
they're acting as the algorithms are
like hypnosis and i understand endorphin
hits and all that but like you can
delete the app
you can
like where is accountability in this
yeah right yeah absolutely we have
alcohol we have tobacco we have drugs we
have weapons and we have all sorts of
issues but most people play within
moderation that's on you yeah and it's a
tough truth right it's a it's a tough
it's a tough it's a tough truth
especially when you're unhappy yeah yeah
that goes back to why it's important
it's like the chicken and egg it's like
working out like i got into better shape
the last eight years nothing comes less
natural to me
yeah nothing comes less natural to me
right like
but like i was like i just would like to
live longer yes i would just like to
live longer yeah and go figure it's not
apple cider
gummies it's not steroids it's not
implants i've thought about them like
can i get chest implants i've put in a
lot of work i feel like i haven't like
set's good like i feel like i'm demonic
but like my body type like you know and
i'm like i probably haven't but uh but
but no it's like eat well
go in the gym yeah do the right things
and so same for life
you know whether it's meditation whether
it's exercise whether it's therapy
whether it's good conversations whether
it's surrounding you know you know back
to us not having to certain you know
we've had some meals we've had some
interactions they're always like they're
nice we need more i would like that yeah
and we'll build on that i think you know
i'm spending more time thinking about
spending more time with more while
doubling down on core
you know yeah
you know because i've been i did a
really good job in the last 10 years of
doubling down on core
but but i think being as busy and i love
what i do
you know i really do want to build out a
more of a friend network more i want to
take more people from
lightweight acquaintance to solid
acquaintance i want to take people from
acquaintance to friend from friend to
best friend and so i'm on a journey like
everybody else but
i think that um
god i think
believe it or not this is going to sound
so crazy for so many
the world
actually has so much potential
for everybody listening
to be
the best time to be alive
medicine and technology and there's so
much but we're caught right now it's
like a hamster wheel we're in the
momentum of focusing on you know the bad
yeah and there's there's always bad yeah
the the holocaust was bad
genocide is always going on genghis khan
was not a fun time to be a human yeah
like you know like we we are very bad at
history i was a really bad student but i
did well in history like but that starts
with you what are you going to do about
it because right now everyone's like
pointing
and feels like it's on someone else yeah
it starts with ourselves i mean when you
said that and you brought up the
holocaust i recently read edith iger's
book the gift she lived through the
holocaust
and she had that mindset in the
holocaust so she said the only way she
got through it is she realized that she
wasn't a prisoner that the only
prisoners were the guards because they
were prisoners of their own conscience
unbelievable that was her mindset she's
right and it's and you know she's like
overnight you know or even older and
it's like
it's just phenomenal that her victor
franco who wrote man search for meaning
these two phenomenal books if anyone
hasn't read them like they had that in
that scenario well that's the point i
always make to everybody like you know
the only thing that works for me is
trying to contextualize moments in time
yeah and like you know our great great
great grandparents had it rough by
comparison the way we have it and sure
they had some things that were better on
simplicity but we must choose optimism
because what's the alternative pessimism
like are you just gonna decide because
once you decide
where are you
once you decide it's bad it's actually
bad
and so like
one of the things that makes me very
passionate to communicate is
practical optimism
or the fact that i believe negativity is
much better at marketing than positivity
oh for sure i feel a huge sense of
responsibility what has become out of
all the things you've pursued because
i'm guessing at different stages in your
life and anyone who hasn't heard i've
interviewed gary twice before so you can
go back and listen to those
you've pursued different things at
different times and every time i meet
you it's a really
what i love about it is that you just
there's so much growth and acceptance
and embracing of this new you every time
we talk i feel like i'm talking to a
even more self-aware human which is a
really fun feeling when you're checking
in with someone in this way
and so i go what what have you found
currently to be the most worthy pursuit
like what is it that you're pursuing
that you've found worthy of it it's
always been the same thing for me
it's almost as if i'm living two
separate lives the most worthy pursuit
is i am wildly gifted
and helping other people and i'm
incredibly comfortable
of also being okay with feeding myself
around my own interests the most
worthwhile pursuit my friends i think is
going to land with you is
the continuous
balance beam that i walk on that is
called equal parts selfish
and equal part selfless and refining
that skill set and i think in the three
times if i may off of your analogy i
think the beam is getting thinner and
i'm still walking it
you know yeah maybe the first time we
met it was like an olympic beam or a
high school beam maybe the second time
was you know my hope is that as i
continue to go i'll be on a tightrope
across manhattan and walk it easily
because
me playing my game of entrepreneurship
gives me so much energy that i'm able to
deploy it
in a positive manner at scale
and i find it fascinating and so that is
what i continue to go after i love that
gary 40 minutes with you feels like an
hour and two hours with someone else
thank you man thank you brother the best
thank you so much
[Music]